Hello Ecuador how are you How are you?
It's official We have a popular consultation These are the 11 questions.
Question number one,
do you agree with the armed forces initiating actions to
prevent and eradicate the activity of transnational criminal
organizations operating inside and outside the national territory.
According to the annex to question number one Question number two,
do you agree that the armed forces
should carry out permanent control of weapons,
ammunition,
explosives and accessories on routes,
roads,
roads and corridors authorized for entry to social rehabilitation centers.
Question number three do you agree that members of the armed forces,
the National Police and the prison security and surveillance
corps should not be deprived of their liberty or ordered
under house arrest for the duration of the investigation or
criminal proceedings for their acts executed with the use of force,
reforming the comprehensive organic criminal code.
In accordance with the annex to question number three question number 4,
do you agree with increasing the penalties
for the crimes of terrorism and their financing,
illicit production and trafficking of catalogued substances subject to control,
organized crime,
murder,
sicariato,
trafficking in persons,
extortionate prostitution,
arms trafficking,
money laundering and illicit activity of mineral resources,
reforming the comprehensive organic penal code According to the annex to
question 4 question number 5 do you agree that persons deprived of their
liberty should serve their full sentence within the social rehabilitation
center in the offenses detailed in the annex to question 5 by reforming
the comprehensive organic criminal code as set out in the aforementioned annex.
Question number 6 do you agree with the
crime of possession or carrying of weapons,
ammunition or components that are for private
use of the armed forces or the National Police,
without affecting firearms allowed for civilian use,
reforming the comprehensive organic penal code.
According to the annex to question number 6 question number 7,
do you agree that weapons,
their parts or pieces,
explosives,
ammunition or accessories that were instruments or material object of a crime
may be intended for the immediate use of the
National Police or the armed forces,
reforming the comprehensive organic criminal code.
In accordance with the annex to question number 7 question number 8,
do you agree with the evaluation of the servants of the judicial function,
including an audit of their asset declarations
according to the annex to question number 8 question number 9,
do you agree with the State proceeding to be
the owner of the assets of illicit or origin,
simplifying the procedure of the Mexican law of extinction of
property of domain as per the annex to question 9 question
number 10 do you agree to reform the procedures for inadmission,
and expulsion of aliens to control migration and strengthen state security.
In accordance with the annex to question 10 and question number 11,
do you agree to allow the operation of casinos,
gambling halls,
gambling houses or businesses dedicated to the conduct of gambling
under the conditions detailed in the annex to question number 11?
These are Ecuadorian the 11 questions that would be raised in this
popular consultation of President Daniel Novoa in approximately 95 days.
The big question is for each of you,
these 11 questions meet the needs that are currently urgent in Ecuador.
Your opinions are super important so I read them here in the
comment box and please share this video to let many people know.